[Music]
you made a very interesting point that
I'm a successful strategy is not really
love optimization but it's about
conversation and deviating from
optimization and for me as a chess
the reason I've always liked chess is
precisely because there is no an
immersive chance and he won't and avoids
in some ways but exactly with some of
trumps so how do you connect well those
two things together the vagaries of
chance to actually meet it
well um you can't always manipulate
chance favorably that's I think that's
the bottom line but what you can do is
actually try to try to just maximize
what you can control so what I always
what I always do what Eric has always
taught me to do is make sure you're
making the right decisions for the right
reasons and so I might play a hand in a
very strange way because I am exploiting
someone who I think is being so because
I'm female one of the things that often
happens is people become much more
aggressive against me because they think
they can get me to fold a lot of hands
and so they'll 3bet me which means
raising my opens much more often with a
lot of weaker hands or you know when I'm
in one of the blinds so I have to be in
the hand they'll raise me much more
widely so they'll do things like that
and then sometimes I'll have a horrible
hand and one that I would never in a
million years floor bet but I'm going to
for bet I'm gonna actually rear ace them
with garbage because I know what's going
on and sometimes I'll run into a really
strong hand but more often than not I
won't and so you can that's what I meant
by exploitation I'm still not going to
be able to get away from the chance
elements that happen in any hand so what
what Eric is always very careful to tell
me is never you know he doesn't care
actually what happens at the end of the
hand he doesn't want to know you know if
I won or lost like at the once the
decision is done it doesn't matter and
so it the outcome you have to divorce
yourself from the outcome
you have to say am i making the right
decision am i thinking about it the
right way at every single step of the
hand can I defend why I'm doing
something even if I'm doing something
really weird that I wouldn't normally do
in a spot like this do I have a reason
for it and if the answer is yes and if
the reason is a good one
then then I played the hand to the best
of my abilities and it actually
sometimes helps when I'm in a tough spot
to know that I'm going to be explaining
this to someone that I'll be explaining
it to Eric or that I'll be explaining it
to Phil or to someone then I then I know
that I actually have to think through my
reasons rather than just act reflexively
which can be very easy to do
sometimes you don't you're like oh I
always do this here I'm just gonna do it
quickly but to actually stop and
question it and then happen what may it
can still be really tough when you make
the right decision and then you end up
losing you know it's not pleasant but
you have to try not to think about that
and to remember that you just made the
best choice you possibly could given the
information that you had available and
sometimes you know it's easy to
criticize other players when you see
them do something really weird you're
like how you know how could you have
done that there but you have to remember
that you see all of the information you
know what hands other people have
because you're watching this on TV they
don't see any of that and they're
actually just acting based on the
information that they do have but all of
that said it's still really sucks to
lose
[Music]